Last semester, we looked at secret
societies
and eschatology, secret history.
This semester, we're doing game theory.
In this class, I want to connect it to
and show you how the world works. Okay?
So, first thing I want to do is go over
some popular conspiracy theories about
how the world works.
And
um there are different variations.
So, I'll just go over a very simplified,
clear version. Okay? And remember, if
there's anything you don't understand,
ask a question.
And make sure you are clear.
Okay. So, we start with the Knights
Templar.
Knights Templar
is probably the most most successful
secret society in the world. It was
founded in the year
uh 1118
as part of the Crusades. So, there were
Christian pilgrims who went to
Jerusalem. Along the way, they would get
robbed. So, Knights Templar was a
volunteer organization
designated by the Vatican
to protect these pilgrims. Now, over
time, what happened was that the Knights
Templar became a bank as well, where
um you could deposit your gold
with the Knights Templar, and they would
give you a receipt, and when you went to
um Jerusalem, they would give you the
gold back. Okay? So, they became a bank,
and as over time, they became
an extremely powerful organization
because they can they were converged of
politics, military, religion, and
finance. And that's why in 1314,
the Catholic Church and the King of
France
made them illegal. Okay? They burned
their leader, Jacques de Molay,
at the stake, and accused him of
blasphemy for worshipping a false god
named Baphomet.
So, the Knights Templars were in
Jerusalem and Jerusalem was convergence
of all religions. So, they started to
become curious about different religions
and start to engage in hermetic
philosophy, neo-Platonism, magic
philosophy, which were all considered
heretical
uh by the Catholic Church, okay? So,
this was a banned organization.
Um and then what happened was that
people speculate that rather than
disappear, the Knights Templars
re-emerged as the Scottish Rite
Freemasons.
>> [snorts]
>> And why they're important
is that they would go on to
um create the Protestant Revolution,
the Protestant Reformation,
as well as the scientific revolution.
They conspired to create the American
Revolution,
as well as the French Revolution.
Basically, they create modernity itself.
They came to control England and create
the Bank of England,
which create the mod- the modern
financial system of
today.
Then they went on to create World War I,
which led to World War II, and now they
conspire to create World War III,
which would then usher in
the a new world government, okay? A one
world government
based in
Jerusalem,
and it'll be controlled by an AI
surveillance state.
And that's why we're seeing
uh data centers built being built all
around the world,
okay?
Um
people also speculate that the Knights
Templars
were able to continue because they had
access to secrets.
Basically, how to
um
communicate with demons, okay?
Interdimensional demons.
Or Lucifer.
And
to communicate with demons, you have to
make contracts with them through ritual
sacrifice.
>> [snorts]
>> And they can And then what they do is
they can take possession of you
and offer you secrets. For example,
um
how to live forever, or how to be young
forever, or how to build great
technology.
Okay? They can also tell you how to like
build nuclear weapons.
And so people speculate that the entire
point of the one world government and
the actual land state is to bring into
our world these interdimensional beings
so that the elite can live forever. So
they can combine with the elite.
There are also people who speculate that
the the Knights Templars
go all the way back to Rome and the 13
families,
which then became part of Venice.
Okay? So there are many different
um
permutations
to this conspiracy theory about how the
world works.
Now, there are lots and lots of issues
with this conspiracy theory about how
the world works, okay? First of all,
there's actually no evidence
that any of this is true.
We don't know if demons actually exist.
There's There's actually no evidence
that demons exist. There's no evidence
that this is a giant conspiracy
that stretched back, you know, a
thousand years. Okay? Second thing is
the elite
don't know that this is true. Okay? The
people believe this is true.
But if you actually go talk to people
who have real power,
they think this is complete and utter
nonsense.
Okay? And the third thing about this is
that it's anti-historical.
Meaning that it is a very simplified
version of how things work. It doesn't
take into account
um other factors as well.
Also,
um what we learn in this class is game
theory. And this is also anti-game
theory. Because one thing that you learn
in this class is that when people are in
power, they become arrogant, hubris.
They become stupid. So, it's very common
for things for powerful people to rise
and then have a spectacular fall, okay?
That's just the iron law of history. So,
for these reasons,
we know this theory is not true.
At the same time,
there are certain things about this
theory that are very compelling.
Okay? So, let's go over some of them.
Well, the first thing about this theory
that's compelling is that it is very
intuitive.
What intuitive just means is that if I
tell to someone,
it makes sense to that person.
It makes a lot more sense than the
history that we're taught in school.
That's kind of strange, right? None of
None of this is correct, but
it's intuitive. Second of Second of all,
is that it's explanatory
in that it help Even though this is not
factual, it does help us understand how
the world works. It's a very clear
explanation. The third thing
that
is the most paradoxical is that it is
predictive.
>> [snorts]
>> Meaning
it helps us
predict how things will turn out in the
future.
And so even though the elite think this
is all insane and there's no way they're
plotting to create World War III,
there's not actually no way that they're
trying to create an actual surveillance
state and create a one-world government,
chances are these things will happen.
Okay?
So, this creates a huge paradox. How is
it that this is not factual?
Okay? This is not at all factual, but it
is truthful.
Meaning it gives us tremendous insight
into how the world works.
All right? So, this is a paradox. This
is all nonsense,
but it helps us predict the future.
So, it's truthful.
So, what I'm going to do now is try to
explain to you how the system really
works, okay? So,
the main thing you need you need to
understand is that this is metaphorical.
Metaphorical.
It is not literal.
Okay?
So, what I'm going to try to try to do
now is try to factually explain to you
why how the world works, okay? And what
you will see is that this is a
metaphorical explanation for how the
world works. It's a good story that
people can understand and help them
appreciate the nuance of this world, but
now I'm going to tell you how it works
literally.
Okay?
All right.
So,
the first thing I'm going to explain to
you
is that there are people in this world,
they're mystics, they're occultists.
And they spend all their time trying to
figure out how the universe works, okay?
They're trying to uncover the secrets of
the universe. And there are different
secrets, right? There's astrology,
okay?
The moving of stars can determine
people's fate, okay? That is of
astrology. Then you have
uh alchemy,
how to turn
nothing into gold, how to turn lead into
gold.
Then you have um eschatology.
Eschatology is how the world will end.
What What's the point of the universe?
When will God come to the earth, okay?
Then you have sacred geometry.
Think of sacred geometry as like
particle physics, which is the
underlying
essence of the universe, okay? So, um
occultists, and these can be poets,
philosophers,
um mystics, they spend all their time
thinking about what is the fundamental
truth of the universe.
And then there are people,
okay? Who seek
power,
wealth,
and fame.
All right?
And what And what they recognize is that
if they really want to seek power,
wealth, and fame, they need to know
these secrets as well.
So, what happens is that
they form secret societies
in order
to access
these secrets of astrology, alchemy,
eschatology, and sacred geometry, and
then implement in the world in order to
create power, wealth, and influence for
themselves. Okay? Does that make sense?
The thing to understand is that there
are many different occultists, many
different secret societies, and they're
all and this all creates very different
combinations.
Okay? But they're all trying to do the
same thing, which is trying to achieve
an eschatology.
All right?
The third element is that
>> [snorts]
>> you need certain individuals in order to
propel society forward in order to
achieve
the eschatology of the secret societies,
okay? And these people are like agents
that the secret societies sponsor. And
historically, these people included
Julius Caesar,
Napoleon,
Hitler,
Stalin.
Today, we have Trump and Putin.
Okay?
All right? So, these are agents or maybe
um Masonic figures or even scapegoats
that secret societies promote in order
to push forward a particular agenda.
All right? And remember that it looks
simple, but it's not because they're
different occultists with different
ideas. And then there are different
secret societies who are competing
against each other and they're promoting
different individuals in order to
achieve their particular vision.
All right? What drives these individuals
like Julius Caesar, Napoleon, Hitler,
Stalin, Trump, and Putin is that they
themselves believe that they that
they're the real
sons of God.
Okay? They're the true Messiah who's
going to lead the world world forward.
And the secret societies and the
occultists are just useful idiots.
Okay? So, this is one framework for
understanding the movement of history.
All right? So, now I'm going to go much
more specific. Okay?
All right.
So, there's another way to frame this,
which is to say that
in the world and society, there are
different
groupings, okay?
So, think of politics.
Think of finance.
Science.
Religion.
Military.
Okay?
Now, the thing about each of these
different fields or disciplines is that
you have a diversity, a range
of behavior
with different belief systems. Okay?
So,
each of these different disciplines have
their own diverse
fields of belief.
At a particular point, there is
convergence.
A convergence
amongst
these different fields.
Okay?
What makes them
converge is the fact that in each field,
you have certain individuals, an extreme
minority, who seek
power,
order, and control.
Okay?
So, again, in each field, you're going
to have a range.
And on one extreme version are those who
hate power, but on the other extreme
version are those who love power. Okay?
And those And people who love power,
order, control of all these different
fields are going to come together, and
they're going to work together in order
to achieve power, order, control, and we
call these people secret societies.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay?
Because you're bound in by a similar
interest.
Now, what's really interesting is that
over time,
as society becomes much more larger,
these different fields expand in size,
creating greater diversity.
And what happens is that this
convergence becomes much stronger in
society. The reason why is that these
different fields are not able to
coordinate together, but the people
inside this convergence are able to
coordinate together, which gives them a
huge advantage in society.
Okay? Which means that they're able to
achieve power, order, and control much
uh
more
uh likely, okay?
So, what's interesting is that as
society declines,
Okay, society declines because it's
become much more bureaucratic, much too
large, much too corrupt, these secret
societies in fact become much more
powerful over time because they're able
to stay much more cohesive.
Okay?
Now,
um once these secret societies are
formed, what you'll discover is that
there are huge
number of these different secret
societies societies. Okay? And And
different individuals can join different
secret societies. And these secret
societies can come from the fact that
they went to a certain school or they
grew up in a certain religion
or their families, okay? There's
different combinations. And these secret
societies are in combination are in
competition with each other. And so,
what the criteria for the competition
are three things, okay? Legitimacy,
authority,
and unity,
cohesion.
Okay?
Why are you more legitimate than other
secret societies? Why do you have more
authority expertise than other secret
societies? Why are you much more unified
than other secret societies, okay? To
solve this problem, what the a societies
will do is they will go back in time and
reimagine history
to show that they are connected
with
the entirety of history.
Okay? So, what they'll say is, "Okay,
well, we got our start not today
in our school, but because we're
connected to the Freemasons, or they're
connected to the Knights Templars,
okay?" So, they go back and create a
cosmology
that explains the origins. And
obviously, the further you go back in
time, the more legitimate
the more authoritative you are. Does
that make sense?
All right. So, they're going to go back
and they're going to create their own
history, and that's why
people think that they
stretch all the way back to Rome.
Okay, even or even maybe Babylon.
And what
allows for people to believe that this
is continuous is the fact that
the elites in each particular time
behave the same way, which is that all
seeking power, order, and control.
And
those who win out have three particular
characteristics, okay?
First of all, these are people who are
addicted
to
power.
They obsess about it. They're obsessive
about it. They will do everything
possible in order to obtain more power.
And
power is expensive and all consuming,
okay?
Meaning they cannot stop but
try to obtain more power.
They behave in such way that looks as
though they are possessed by demons.
Okay? And in fact, they do worship
demons. And the reason why is they think
they worship all gods in the search for
reason.
Okay? They are looking for the greatest
secrets of the universe, so they are
open-minded. They are looking for all
possibilities. They will worship
Lucifer, but they will also worship
Baphomet. They will They will worship
Osiris. They will worship Isis.
Okay?
So, now we understand how the world
works literally.
Throughout history, the elites have
behaved the same way.
Okay? And even though
um these elites are fighting with each
other, they are put They are moving
forward an agenda that consolidates
power onto the hands of a few people,
which gives the impression that this is
all a continuous
agenda cons- controlled by a few people.
Okay? Does this all make sense, guys?
All right? So, remember, this is the
um metaphorical understanding of how the
world works,
a world controlled by a particular
secret society, the Knights Templar who
became the Freemasons who then became
the Illuminati
who control the world today and they're
trying to usher in a one-world gov-
government
uh and they they actually run the state
and summon demons into this world in
order to live forever, okay?
So, this is the grand conspiracy. But
again, it doesn't it doesn't um explain
why we have no evidence, why the elite
don't think they're part of this, and
why this is anti-historical, okay? But
once we we transform this into a literal
explanation, and this is the literal
explanation, this explains everything.
Okay? The elite don't think there's a
conspiracy because they're too busy
fighting each other. They're not looking
at the grand scheme of things. Whereas
the people who are not involved in this
game can look at the moving history and
have can come to an intuitive
understanding of how this thing moves
and it's moving towards more control,
more order, and more power.
Okay?
And this helps helps us explain why
the system persists even though the
elites will rise and they will fall.
Because these elites are already in
competition with with each other. So,
what's happening is that certain elites
are replacing other elites, but they all
have the same agenda, which is more
power, more order, more control. Okay?
Does it make sense, guys?
Okay? And that's why we actually we the
texts
of these secret societies,
all of these thinkers, they look as
though they are
building on top of each other even
though they probably have not read and
read each other, okay?
People who seek power
are very much
alike.
They're different from you and me and
that they're probably psychopaths.
Okay? All they care about is power and
so powerful people come together in
order to create more power for
themselves. Okay? Does it make sense,
guys? Okay. So, now what what we're
going to do is we're going to go over
the evidence, okay? So, what what I want
to first do is discuss this man. His
name is Albert Pike.
And he was born in year 1809 to 1891.
And what is important is that he's
considered the grand architect of
American Freemasonry.
Why American Freemasonry is important is
that it's the people who control the
American government. 1/3 of all American
presidents were Freemasons.
Okay? And these people today control the
American military, the national security
apparatus, the CIA, the FBI.
All right? They are called the
Freemasons,
but they go back with Freemasons. So,
they share the similar ideas of the
Freemasons. So, um
Albert Pike is was one of the major
leaders of the American Freemasons, and
he's considered the grand architect,
meaning that he built the system and the
ideas that underpin modern day American
Freemasonry today. His most important
work is called Morals and Dogma. And
it's basically the standard textbook
of American Freemasonry, okay?
So, we're going to look at a few
passages from Morals and Dogma. And I
know they're a bit long, but it's very
important for us to understand how they
think.
Okay? So, um
I'm going to read the first part, and
then Alan, if you can help me read this
part, okay? So, I'll I'll read the first
part.
The rough ashlar, okay, this is the
ashlar, guys, which is a stone, is the
people as a mass, rude and unorganized.
So, society is diverse. It's chaotic.
And we, the Freemasons, our objective in
life is to create order out of chaos.
The perfect ashlar, okay, our cubical
stone, symbol perfection, is the state.
The purpose of government is to create
order out of chaos, to perfect
humanity.
The rulers deriving their powers from
the consent of the governed, the
Constitution and laws speaking the will
of the people, the government
harmonious, symmetrical, efficient, its
powers properly distributed and building
adjusted in equilibrium. Okay? So, think
of society as a forest. No, a forest is
chaotic. There are diseases in a forest.
It could burn down. What we really want
to do is create a temple of stone that
is perfect, that is eternal, that is
divine. Okay? We want to burn down the
forest and build a temple with our bare
hands. I know God
uh the one who created the forest, but
God willed us to perfect his work.
If we dealing in a cube on the on a
plane service, okay? We have visible
three faces and nine external lines
drawn between seven points. The complete
cube has three more faces making six,
three more lines making 12, and one more
point making eight. As number 12
includes the sacred numbers 3 5 7 and 3
* 3 or 9 is produced by adding the
sacred number three to nine, while its
own two figures, one to the unit of
monad and duad added together make the
same sacred number three. It was called
the perfect number.
And the cube became a symbol of
perfection, okay? So, this is God.
What we're trying to do is we're trying
to create God on Earth. And how we know
it's God? Because it is perfection
itself. How do we know How do we know
it's perfection? Because of mathematics,
geometry, okay? Geometry is a language
of God. Once you understand geometry,
you understand how God thinks. So,
the cube is perfect, so we want to turn
society into a cube. In fact, we're
turning everyone into a cube. And how do
we do so?
Artificial intelligence, guys, okay?
Artificial intelligence. Okay. All
right. So, again,
uh the So, the idea is we we want to
read them in order to understand the
essence of their thinking. Okay, so
let's uh now move on, okay? Uh can you
read um Alan?
Nevertheless, masonry, which is morality
and philosophy, must not cease to do its
duty. We never know at what moment
success awaits our efforts. Generally,
when most unexpected, nor with what
expect or efforts are or are not to be
attended. Succeed or fail, masonry must
not bow to arrow or succumb under
discouragement. There was at Rome a few
Carthaginian soldiers taken prisoners
who refused to bow to Flamininus and had
a little of Hannibal's mag- magnanimity.
Mason should possess an equal greatness
of soul. Masonry should be an energy
finding its aim and effect in the
ameliorations of mankind. So Socrates
Socrates should enter into Adam and
produce mar- Marcus Aurelius.
In other words, bring forth from the man
of enjoyments, the man of wisdom.
Masonry should not be a mere watchtower
built upon mystery from which to gaze at
ease upon the world with no other result
than to be a convenience for the
curious, to hold the full cup of thought
to the thirsty lips of men, to give all
the true ideas of deity, to harmonize
conscious and science
are the province of philosophy.
Morality is faced in full bloom.
Contemplation should lead to action and
the absolute be practical.
The ideal be made air and food and drink
to the human mind. Wisdom is a sacred
communion
communion. It is only on that condition
that it cease to be a
sterile love of science and becomes the
one and supreme method by which to unite
humanity and arouse it to concerted
action. Then philosophy become religion.
>> Okay. So, Freemasonry is the ultimate
religion. Why? Because it encompasses
all previous religions including
Egyptian
hermeticism, okay? Including the Greek
mystery
cults of Pythagoras.
Uh including the Kabbalah. Okay? So, it
has score it has scouted entire
history and found the best ideas of
humanity and put them together
to create Freemasonry. And the ultimate
goal is for each of us to become a
stone, stoic,
unrelenting,
perfect faith.
And then
if we build if we put all humanity
together and we're all stones, then we
can we can create the perfect temple of
God. Okay, we can create God on Earth.
So, imagine a pyramid where all stone in
the pyramid. And we all have a
responsibility to become that stone
through faith, through practice, through
reflection, okay? So, Socrates should
enter into Adam and produce Marcus
Aurelius. So, the height of humanity is
reflection and reason where we surrender
our emotions to geometry.
Okay? All right, let's keep on going.
All right, so does that all make sense
so far? All right, let's keep on going.
All right, can you read uh Alan?
>> [snorts]
>> Man owned it to himself to be free. He
owned it to his country to seek to give
her freedom or maintain her in that
possession. And made tyranny and uh
usurpations the enemies of the human
race, it created a general out out lawry
out lawry of despots and despotisms,
temporary and spiritual.
The sphere of duty was immensely
immensely enlarged. Uh patriotism had
henceforth a new and wider meaning. Free
government, free thought, free
conscience, free speech. All these came
to be inalienable rights which those who
had parted with them or being robbed of
them who
or whose ancestors had lost them had the
right sum- summarily summarily to
retake. Unfortunately, as truth always
become perverted into falsehood and our
falsehoods when misapplied, this truth
become the gospel of anarchy soon after
it was first preached.
Masonry early comprehended this truth
and recognized its own enlarged duties.
Its symbols then came to have a wider
meaning, but it also assumed the must of
stone masonry and borrow its working
tools and so was supplied with new and
apt symbols. It aided in bringing about
the French Revolution disappear with the
uh
Girondist Girondist was born against
with the restoration of order and
sustained Napoleon. Because though
emperor, he acknowledged the right of
the people to select its rules and was
at the head of nation refusing to
receive back its old kings. Okay, stop.
Okay, all right. Okay, great. Okay. So,
what he's doing what Albert Pike is
doing is trying to explain the
eschatology of Freemasonry, okay? The
eschatology is this. We want to create
an empire of reason. Okay? What what
what he calls a holy empire of reason.
And for that, we must
create revolutions around the world.
Okay? And what he's doing is he's trying
to say that this is a crusade and we go
back to the time of the Knights
Templars.
And we were the ones who brought about
the French Revolution and created
Napoleon in order to achieve this holy
reason of empire. Okay? So, what he's
doing is he's going back into the
history and rewriting history to show
that the Freemasons were the end point
of history. The natural evolution of the
Knights Templars. Also, what he's trying
to tell tell people is that we do things
in secret because before we were the
Knights Templars, the French and the and
the Catholic Church
hunted us down. So, we had to disguise
ourselves under stonemasonry, okay? So,
that's why we took the guise of the
Freemasons because the Freemasons were
just a workers guild who built temples.
And we took their shape in order to
protect protect ourselves and then to
try to promote our mission in secret.
Okay? All right? So, this is why people
believe that the Freemasons come from
the Knights Templars. What this is
really doing is it's trying to bring
legitimacy and authority to the
Freemasons by reimagining history as a
movement towards Freemasonry. It doesn't
make sense, guys. Okay? So, he talks
about how the Freemasons not only
created the French Revolution, they
brought but they brought about Napoleon
in order to try to create um a one-world
government, okay? And that failed, but
if Napoleon failed, don't worry, America
will succeed.
>> [snorts]
>> Uh this is another passage we will not
read, but he talks about how
um the Freemasons actually
created conditions for the French
Revolution and conspired for
generations for decades in order to
avenge the death of their lost leader
Jacques de Molay in 1314, okay? So, the
Freemasons think centuries ahead and
they plan decades in advance. And again,
this is all to create legitimacy and
authority for their movement. This is a
rewriting of history. It is none of this
is true,
okay?
All right, let's continue.
>> [snorts]
>> All right, can you read um Alan?
The degree of Rose is devoted to and
symbolizes the final triumph of
truth over falsehood or of liberty over
slavery, of light over darkness or life
over death, and of good over evil. The
great truth it inculcates is that
notwithstanding the existence of evil,
God is infinitely wise, just, and good.
And though the fears of of the world
proceed by no rule of right and wrong
known to us in the narrowest of our
views, yet all is right, for it is the
work of God, and all evils, all
miseries, all misfortunes are but as
drops in the vast current that is
sweeping our world. Guided by him to a
great and magnificent result, that at
the appointed time he will redeem and
regenerate the world, and the principle,
the power, and the existence of evil
will then cease. And this will be
brought about by such means and its
instruments as he chooses to employ,
whether by the merits of a redeemer that
has already appeared, or Messiah that is
yet waited for, by an incarnation of
himself, or by an by prophet. It does
not belong to us as Masons to decide.
Let each judge and believes for himself.
In the meantime, we labor to hasten the
coming of that day. Okay, let's go
through the rules. Okay, the idea here
is that
the Freemasons and I
Knights Templar were so successful
because they were secret society, but
first and foremost, they were a company.
They were a hierarchy.
Okay?
So, they were like a triangle.
And to climb the hierarchy, you have to
constantly reinvent yourself. You have
to adopt new ideas, and based on your
performance, based on your ideology,
they will promote you to a new rank,
okay? So, in Scottish Rite Freemasonry,
there are 33 ranks.
And you just climb up higher and higher,
and each each time you you climb the
rank, they will teach you a new way of
understanding the world. And based on
your fluidity, based on your mental
flexi- flexibility, you will climb
higher and higher, okay? So, they're
they're trying they're trying to train
you into a mastery of knowledge.
Okay, and that's why they're so
successful.
All right, can you can you can you read
um
Alan? Let us, in order to understand
this old thought, first follow the soul
and its descent. The sphere or heaven of
the fixed stars was that holy region,
and those
Elysian Elysian fields that were that
native domicile of souls and the place
to which they reascended when they had
recovered their prim- primitive purity
and simplicity. From that luminous
region that the soul set forth when it
joined journal toward the body, a
destination which it did not reach until
it had undergone three degra-
degradations designated
by the name of that
>> Okay, stop. Okay, all right. So, this
passage just shows you
that the Freemasons are trying to
incorporate all philosophies, including
the Kabbalah, sorry.
The
um Kabbalah,
the uh Gnosticism,
and Hermetic philosophy, okay? And as a
result, they try to be the complete,
okay? So, the main advantage is in their
completeness,
meaning they have an explanation for
everything. So, what what they're trying
to tell us is that we are first and
foremost souls that came from heaven.
And why do we come to heaven? To
experience the world.
And we become trapped in our bodies
because our bodies want to experience
sensual pleasures, but our souls want to
only experience spiritual pleasures. So,
the world is a spiritual war in
ourselves between our material selves,
which wants sex, food, and money, and
our spiritual selves that seek
connection and with reason.
Okay? And the way to
defeat ourselves is through geometry, by
turning ourselves into a sacred cube
that connects back to the divine.
All right?
Okay, can you can you can you read um
Yeah.
Alan.
Question. What is to us the chief symbol
of man's ultimate redemption and
regeneration? Answer. The fraternal
super Supper. Uh supper of bread which
nourish
and of wine which refreshed and ex
Exhilarates. Exhilarates symbolic
uh symbolic
symbolical of the time which is to come
when all mankind shall be one great
harmonious brotherhood and teaching us
these great lessons that as matter
changes ever but no single atom is
annihilated. Annihilated. Annihilated.
Okay, all right, stop. Okay. All right.
So, this is the idea of fraternity.
And how do you create a fraternity?
Well,
the simple way is to engage in a supper
together, okay? Just like Jesus and the
last supper and to share communion,
okay? That is that a communion.
So, that you all feel connected with
each other. But over time because there
are certain elements of the Freemasons,
Knights Templars, who want power
order and control, they engage in more
extreme practices. And so, what they
will do literally is they will
eat
the dead corpse
of an old Freemason in order to connect
themselves to each other as well as to
their past.
Okay?
They believe that the Freemasons, if
through tremendous spiritual sacrifice,
are able to
um
congregate inhabit spiritual energy that
still resides in the body. So, they will
dig up the corpse and then
eat that corpse in a communion in a in a
dinner, okay?
All right? So, again, the Freemason
societies is that those who are the most
extreme, those who are most fanatical,
will win out in the end.
Okay?
All right. So, can you continue um Yeah.
You have heard more than one definition
of Freemasonry.
The truth and the most significant you
have yet to hear it is taught to the
entered apprentice, the fellow craft,
and the master, and it is taught in
every degree through which you have
advanced to it is. It is a definition of
what Freemasonry is, of what its purpose
is, and its very essence and spirit are,
and it has for every one of us the
forces and uh sense sense to sense today
of a divine law, and impose on every one
of us a solemn obligations. It is
symbolized and taught to the apprentice
as well as to you by the compass and the
square, upon which as well as upon the
book of your religion and the book of
law of the Scottish Freemasonry, you
have taken so many obligations. As a
knight, you have been taught by the
swords, the symbols of honor and duty on
which you have taken your vows.
Vows, it was taught you by the balance,
the symbol of all equilibrium, and by
the cross, the symbol of the wholeness
and self-sacrifice. And all that these
teach and contain is taught and
contained for entered apprentice,
knight, and prince alike by the compass
and the square.
For the apprentice, the points of the
compass are beneath the square. For the
fellow craft fellow craft, one is above
and one beneath. For the masters, both
are dominant and have rule, control, and
empire over the symbol of the early and
the material. Freemasonry is the
subjugations of the human that is in man
by the divine, the conquest of the
appetites and passions by the moral
sense and the reason. A continual
effort, struggle, and welfare of the
spiritual against the material and
sensual. That victory, when it has been
achieved and
secured, and the conqueror may rest upon
his shield and wear the well-earned
laurel as the true only empire. Okay,
the true only empire of reason, okay?
So, let me explain to you the simple
symbolism of Freemasonry. This is the
compass, okay? What does a compass do? A
compass sets the boundaries. It rules,
right? This is a square, okay? The
square limits, okay? So, the idea is
that when you first join Freemasonry,
you have to focus on the square, which
is your own spiritual alchemy,
okay? To
discipline yourself, to focus yourself,
to learn how to be ruled, okay? By the
compass.
Then, you reach a point where you must
rule yourself. So, you must teach others
how to be disciplined, how to be
focused.
And then you reach a point when you
combine the square and the compass,
which is you lead the Freemasons to
control the whole world to create the
holy empire of reason.
All right? So, according to different
ranks, you see the symbol in a different
way.
All right. The
the G, what what does a G stand for?
Well, there are three different
interpretations, okay? There are It
stands for uh geometry, of course,
because of the square and the and the uh
compass. It stands for God or Gnosticism
or grand architect, okay? So, what the
Freemasons believe is that there is a
God, but he created this world for us to
perfect ourselves, then God left us. So
he's the architect, but that means that
we have responsibility to renovate
and perfect the world that we live in,
okay? And but there's also um people
believe that the G stands for the
generative principle.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay? So
there's male and there's female. The the
female is a productive principle, the
thing that gives birth. The male is a
generative principle, the thing that
uh energizes the female.
Okay? So what's interesting is that if
you put all this together, you put uh
generative principle, generate, plus
geometry,
what you get is God.
Okay? And what does generative and
geometry equal? It equals AI.
Artificial intelligence.
So at the very beginning of Freemasonry,
there was an impetus, a desire among
them to create to prove that they could
be God by creating life itself.
All right? In the beginning they call
this golems.
But now you think about it,
that's why they want to create AI.
To prove that they can be God
themselves. Once you Once you create AI,
then you perfect the world.
Okay? So that is Freemasonry, and you
can see how it gives rise now to
artificial intelligence.
I'm not saying that they planned for
artificial intelligence, but I'm saying
is that the people in charge now of of
artificial intelligence are going to be
people like Sam Altman, Peter Thiel,
Larry Ellison, Elon Musk. They can They
can all go They can all go back to to
this tradition and
um
basically appropriate this tradition in
order to justify
their AI surveillance state.
All right?
Okay. So now let's move on.
This is Zbigniew Brzezinski.
And he was national security advisor to
Jimmy Carter, okay? Who Who was
president of the United States
and he's a founder of something called
the Trilateral Commission.
Which basically tries to implement
American grand strategy
in the world.
And
uh this is This is funded by David
Rockefeller. Who Who obviously was one
of the wealthiest, most powerful
Americans to ever live. So, this is a
very powerful individual.
And we're going to read certain
um writings from his book Between Two
Ages.
And when we read it, you'll see how
similar it is to Albert Pike. Now, I
don't think that Zbigniew Brzezinski
read Albert Pike.
And he he's He probably himself is He
himself is probably not a Freemason.
But again, you don't have to read Albert
Pike. You don't have to be a Freemason
to think like them. These are These are
all people obsessed with power, control,
and order. And they're going to look for
elements of different religions in order
to justify their
um pursuit of power, order, and control,
okay? So, this is from the book Between
Two Ages.
Uh can you read
um
Alan?
The emergence of a large dominant party
alongside the more narrowly focuses and
more intensively doctrinal uh
group group groupings on the right and
the left could accelerate the trend
towards such technological uh
managerialism.
Such a large dominant party would
combine American society's quest for
stability with its historical affinity
for innovation. Relying on scientific
growth to produce the means for dealing
with social ills, it would tap the
nation's
intellectual talent for broad target
planning and exploit the existence of
doctrinal groups by using them as social
parameters and as sources of novel
ideas. Persisting social crisis, the
emergence of
charismatic personality, and the
exploitation of mass media to obtain
public confidence would be the stepping
stones in the piecemeal transformations
of the United States into a highly
controlled society. In different ways,
both the doctrinal doctrinarian and the
conservative might find the temptations
inherent in the new
techniques of social social control too
difficult to resist. The inclinations of
the doctrinal left to legitimize means
by ends could lead them to justify more
social control on the ground that it
serves progress. The conservative
conservatives
preoccupied with public order and
fascinated by modern
gadgetry
would be tempted to use the new
technique as a response to unrest. Since
they would fail to recognize that social
control is not the only way to deal with
rapid social change. So this is your
written in the This book is written
about 1970s, okay? This is like 40-50
years ago.
What's amazing about this paragraph is
that it perfectly describes America
today.
This is not just a prophecy, it's almost
like a plan, okay? So So So let me
explain what what he's saying. He's
saying that democracy is problematic.
Why? Because it always leads to
polarization.
You're going to always going to have
different factions within this within
this democracy who are going to fight
each other. Eventually, you're going to
reach a point where they actually refuse
to get along. That's what's happening in
America today between the left and the
right, between the Democrats and
Republicans, okay?
He's And he's saying this is going to
create a series of crises. Uh social
crisis.
And the solution he believes is a
technocracy.
All right?
So, basically
a bureaucracy in Washington D.C. run by
engineers who use artificial
intelligence, who use data and
statistics in order to better govern
society, and who are better able to use
this social polarization in order to
better manage society.
Okay? And And this is a really, really
interesting
sentence.
Persisting social crises. Okay? So,
what's happening in America right now is
the divide between the left and right.
The emergence of a charismatic
personality. Who's that person?
Charismatic personality? Donald Trump,
guys.
And the exploitation of mass media,
okay? So, just basically social media in
order to indoctrinate and brainwash you.
To obtain public confidence would be the
stepping stones in the piecemeal
transformation of the United States into
a highly controlled society. A A.I.
surveillance state.
So, what he's saying is this.
Eventually, you'll reach a point where
the divide will be so vast, the economy
will be in such trouble,
um the people will be so angry that they
will demand a Napoleon or Julius Caesar
to arise to lead them into a
dictatorship. And this could be a good
thing because this could create a
technocracy, which would be better able
to govern society, okay?
All right? So, this is a continuation of
the Freemason project of trying to
create order out of chaos.
All right? And what he's saying is this.
It will be the conservatives, the
Republicans,
who will win out in the civil war
because they're the ones who are occu-
preoccupied with public order and
gadgetry, okay? They are the ones who
will who will want the A.I. surveillance
state.
Okay? Once you have the actual state,
you now have the technocracy.
And the world will be perfect.
All right, does it make sense you guys?
What is saying here? This is an amazing
paragraph written 40, 50 years ago. So
I'm not saying he's a Freemason, I'm not
saying he's part of civil society, but
he sure thinks like a Freemason.
All right, let's continue.
All right, can you can you?
It was a frontier tradition that stirred
American imagination, created a society
of movement and growth, and gave
American its integrative myth.
Scientific explorations, including
exploration of space, has become the
functional equivalent of Americans
frontier tradition. And such endeavor is
immediately relevant to the educational
and scientific attainment of the
country. Okay, stop. Okay, can you just
read the the last paragraph? To many
Americans To many Americans,
contemporary
liberalism offers neither principles nor
progress. The crisis of American
liberalism is hence both a crisis of
confidence and of historical relevance.
>> Okay, so what he's saying here is that
democracy was a historical accident. It
was good for America before, but in the
future
liberalism will probably be a bad thing.
Okay, because it's too divisive.
Okay? So so what's the solution then?
Well, you're you're
>> [cough]
>> This is this is the solution.
Can you read, [clears throat] please?
Yeah.
That is why Can you be slower, please,
Alan? Okay, you don't have to rush.
Okay, just just read it slower. Keep on
going. That is why Marxism represents a
further virtual and creative stage in
the maturing of man's universal vision.
Marxism is simultaneously a victory of
the external active man over the inner
passive man and a victory of reason over
belief. It stresses man's capacity to
shape his material destiny.
Finnis
>> Okay, stop. Okay, all right. So, this is
an amazing passage, okay?
This is the guy who was national
security advisor to Jimmy Carter.
At this time, this is the height of the
Cold War. America's fighting a war with
the Soviet Union.
And the national security advisor of the
United States
to Jimmy Carter says that democracy is
bad, Marxism is good.
Okay?
Marxism is good. Why? Because it is the
end point of history.
The French Revolution was about
promoting reason over emotion.
Marxism is a natural progression of the
French Revolution. Marxism is what
promises
um a victory of reason over emotion.
Okay? So, what is the AI civil state?
Ultimately, it is techno-Marxism.
Okay? That's what they want.
Through our communism.
National security advisor to Jimmy
Carter, one of the most powerful
Americans in the world, wants Marxism.
Why? Because Marxism, communism is
the implementation of the ideas of
Freemasonry in our world.
All right?
Okay.
Is this clear, guys?
All right. Um Mr. Jen, Yes.
So, but what is the tech
techno-Marxism?
Yeah, I'll I'll I'll I'll explain, okay?
>> Okay. All right. So, this is Larry
Ellison. And Larry Ellison probably
doesn't read books.
Okay, he's probably never read Albert
Pike. He's probably never read uh
Zbigniew Brzezinski, okay? But he's one
of the most powerful men in America
because he founded a company called
Oracle.
All right? And this is him with Donald
Trump announcing something called
Operation
Stargate. So they're going to build like
data centers all around the United
States in order to create their AI
within state.
Now,
Larry Ellison is most powerful is one of
the most powerful men in the world, but
his background is very very interesting.
He founded a company uh Oracle. Uh at at
the time it was called R I RSI. This is
from uh a biography of Larry Ellison
called The Difference Between God and
Larry Ellison, okay? And it talks about
how in the first 5 years
his company was terrible.
They were a database company designed to
collect data and then organize this data
in a way that was useful to companies
and to governments, okay?
But they were so bad that you put data
into this computer, they lost all the
data.
They were just incompetent.
But
who were the clients? It's the CIA and
the Navy who had unlimited money.
Okay?
So the company's incompetent,
destroys data,
but the government kept on supporting
them, okay? Can can you read, Alan?
The funny thing was the early customers
did not really mind losing money or
data. Even though RSI never really
delivered what the CIA wanted, the
agency was not upset. Engineer Kirk
Bradley remembered a CIA employee
telling him, "We bought the things
knowing damn well it wasn't going to
work. We're buying an idea." Added or it
states tape due to or did not satisfy
the Navy either,
but it did not matter. We were buying a
right flip-flyer with the expectations
that we would probably have an airline
in the few years. The Navy John scale
said, "The Navy understood that Oracle
might crash and burn at all any time,
yet it was exciting to try to make it
fly."
Shields added with a hint of irony. This
is really confusing, okay? The CIA, the
Navy, you're going to hire a company
because a company's going to do it
cheaper and faster and more effectively
than you can do it, right?
But what happened with Oracle is that it
cost a lot of money, they weren't
getting what they wanted,
and they had to put their own resources
to create Oracle. They had to help
Oracle
come into being. So, Oracle and Larry
Ellison are both creations of the CIA
and the Navy.
Why would they do that?
Okay?
That's a very curious question. I don't
know the answer to this.
It might be because Larry Ellison is
just a really charismatic guy, and maybe
because he has relatives who work for
the CIA, and maybe because he got really
lucky. Who knows?
But this is a very curious fact about
how these companies like Oracle started.
All right?
>> [snorts]
>> We're also going to talk about this guy,
Peter Thiel. Peter Thiel is probably one
of the most powerful men in America
right now. He's actually much more
powerful than Elon Musk. Why? Because in
2016, he recognized the potential in
Donald Trump, and he supported Donald
Trump's campaign. He also saw the
potential in J.D. Vance, and he
supported uh J.D. Vance's uh venture
capital career, as well as his Senate
race, and then he promoted J.D. Vance as
the VP for Donald Trump, okay? And when
you read Peter Thiel, even though he's
an entrepreneur, he actually reads like
a Freemason. It's really, really
strange. Okay, so this is from his book
from
zero to one.
Okay, he's talking about how to build a
great company.
What he tells you is this.
If you want to build a great company to
compete against other companies, you're
an idiot. Competition is for losers.
Capitalism is for losers. What you want
is monopoly. What you want is communism.
What you want is to dominate.
Okay, and that means you need a secret
in order to monetize. Okay, can you can
you read, Allen? Can you read slowly,
please? Yeah.
There are two kinds of secrets, secrets
of nature and secrets about people.
Natural secrets exist all around us. To
find them, one must study some
undiscovered aspects of the physical
world. Secrets about people are
different. There are things that people
don't know about themselves or things
they hide because they don't want others
to know.
So, when thinking about what kinds of
company to build, there are two distinct
questions to ask. What secrets is nature
not telling you? What secrets are people
not telling you? If you find a secret,
you're faced a choice. Some are more
dangerous than others. As Faust tells
Wagner, "The few who know what might be
learned, foolish enough to put their
whole heart on snow and reveal their
feelings to the crowd below, mankind had
always crucified and burned."
Unless you have perfectly conventional
beliefs, it is rarely a good idea to
tell everybody everything that you know.
So, what you tell whoever you need to
and no more. In practice, there always a
god golden means between telling nobody
and telling everybody, and that's a
company. The best entrepreneurs know
this. Every great business is built
around a secret that's hidden from the
outside. A great company is a conspiracy
of change the world. When you share your
secret, the recipient becomes a fellow
conspirator. How do you build a great
company? You create a secret society.
All right? And what's And what's a
secret society? You access the occult.
Okay? If you really want to make a lot
of money, guys, don't spend your time
programming and looking for the best
technology. Don't do that. That's a
waste of time. Look at the occult.
Figure out the secrets of humanity.
Figure out the secrets of of the occult
and build your company around that idea,
and you will come to dominate.
All right? So,
uh he also he he's very clear about
this, okay? He's What he's saying is
that if you if you want to start a
company, start a religion first, man.
Okay, can you read, Alan?
>> Yeah.
The best startups might be considered
slightly less extreme kinds of cults.
The biggest difference is that cults
tend to be fanatically wrong about
something important. People at a
successful startup are fanatically right
about something those outside it have
missed. You're not going to learn those
kinds of secrets from consultants, and
you don't need to worry if your company
doesn't make sense to conventional
professionals. Better to be called a
cult or even a mafia. Okay. All right.
Okay, this does make sense, okay? He's
saying it literally now. Start a
religion or start a mafia. It doesn't
matter, okay?
Um now, Peter Thiel is important because
he had he is a mentor to two
individuals, Mark Zuckerberg as well as
Sam Altman. Remember from last from last
week, uh we read Karen House's book uh
Empire of AI, where Sam Altman says that
the most successful founders do not set
out to create companies. They are on a
mission to create something closer to a
religion.
All right? So, he's basically
um
using the words of his mentor, Peter
Thiel.
Um this is also what Sam Altman said.
People talk about how much energy it
takes to train an AI model, but it also
takes a lot of energy to train a human.
It takes like 20 years of life and all
the food you eat during that time before
you get smart. Okay? So, these people
literally see see no difference between
an AI and a human. You're just energy to
be exploited.
Okay? You're just an energy that I need
to turn into a cube in order to create
my holy temple of reason.
Right? And this is P And this is another
uh friend of Peter
uh Thiel's called Asana Corp who And
then together they found a company
called Palantir. What is Palantir?
Palantir is the ultimate AI civilian
company. Okay? So, Oracle creates
databases
of information. Everything about you is
on in the Oracle database.
Palantir then takes this information and
predicts how you'll behave.
Okay?
And this is the
uh Palantir manifesto called the
Technological Republic. It's it They
They're not Freemasons, but they might
as well be Freemasons, okay? So, uh this
is the manifesto and it basically says
that
we need to create a technocracy. That's
all it's saying. We We're going to
create a technocracy.
And that's a done state. And that's a
good thing.
All right?
All right. And I will leave you with
this.
Peter Thiel
for the past few years has been giving
speeches around the world talking about
the Antichrist. Okay? What's the
Antichrist? How much does the Antichrist
rise to power? By playing on our fears
of technology and seducing us into
darkness with the Antichrist's slogan
peace and safety. The Antichrist is
anyone
and everyone who opposes the AI civilian
state. Okay? So, you might think, "No,
no, no. Wait. Isn't it more logically to
believe that the AI civilian state is
the Antichrist?" NO. PETER THIEL is
saying, "NO, IT'S THE OPPOSITE, GUYS.
It's You oppose
the AI civilian state, then you're the
Antichrist. The Antichrist is evil.
Therefore, we have to destroy these
people. Okay? Whoever prevents us from
building the actual civil state is pure
evil.
And once you understand this, then we
will we will achieve our holy empire of
reason.
Okay?
Any questions, guys?
So, can we understand the Freemasonry,
which is the kingdom of reason, as a
kind of brainwash?
>> [snorts]
>> Okay.
Freemasonry
is
a group of people who practice certain
things. And at the very heart of
Freemasonry is an eschatological vision
of trying to achieve the end of the
world,
which is a one world government based in
Jerusalem,
and where everyone obeys this
government. And if you if you obey, then
the world is perfect.
Okay? Does that make sense? Yeah. Okay?
And so, how how how do you get people to
obey? AI, right?
You don't want to work out? You don't
want to study? You don't want to work
and pay taxes? Well, let's have an AI in
your head, a microchip in your head that
tells you, "No, no, no, Vincent, you
should pay your taxes. No, no, no,
Vincent, you shouldn't drive drunk."
Okay?
And that's the idea. It's about alchemy,
human perfection,
trying to turn you into an obedient
robot that can be programmed.
Okay? Does that make sense?
But it's a good thing.
Because once we do that, there'll be
peace, there'll be happiness, there'll
be safety. It's a good thing.
Yeah?
But if that was a good thing, like what
matters about human subjectivity? If the
AI fully controls you?
>> Human subjectivity is bad because it
leads to sin. It leads to errors. It
leads to confusion.
You understand? If we all think alike,
the world is now perfect. We now achieve
a common brotherhood of humanity. We now
achieve God. If everyone thinks alike,
that's what AI can do for us.
Any more questions?
Okay. So, Putin is coming to Beijing
tonight. So, on Thursday, we'll discuss
Putin.